revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez más de ella conmigo
en el estudio de esta mañana de jueves
rosa bienvenida a morir y entonces esta
revista de prensa hoy 14 de julio que se
celebra en francia el día nacional con
un tema que salpica estos días al actual
presidente de la república estamos
hablando de manuel macro por supuesto y
son sus vínculos secretos con los
lobbies de grandes compañías sobre todo
cuando era ministro de economía esto
entre los años 2014 y 2016 rosa buenos
días raúl efectivamente no y el medio de
investigación mediapart va un poco más
allá y tal y como nos cuentan en este
reportaje solicitaron en 2019 los
mensajes entre el poder ejecutivo entre
el elíseo y grandes compañías las
llamadas gafas recordemos hacer
referencia a estas siglas a google apple
facebook a manson y microsoft bien el
elíseo se negó a pasar a este vídeo de
comunicación de investigación a
mediapart estos documentos alegando una
especie de secreto comercial pero
finalmente un tribunal administrativo ha
dado razona este medio de comunicación
por lo que les ha dado acceso a decenas
de documentos que como decíamos
muestran la relación entre el poder
político francés entre manuel macrón y
sus consejeros y a grandes empresas
particularmente google y amazon bien
para resumir un poco todo lo que se
extrae de estos documentos es a tal y
como dice el periodista alexandra
lesioné quien ha hecho toda esta
investigación es básicamente cómo se
creó un discurso común sobre los
beneficios de la implantación de estas
empresas en el territorio francés no un
poco una colisión entre el poder
político y el económico que recuerda
mucho a la investigación que hemos
abordado aquí ampliamente que son estas
archivos no estos papeles de uber y es
que precisamente tal y como el lobbista
que fue informante el que pasó al medio
británico the guardian a todos los
documentos de secretos de uber que
dieron pie a esta investigación global
marc magán participó en la campaña de
macrón de 2017 nos cuenta este artículo
también nos revela que jang gon y un
lobbista de amazona también participó en
el seno de la campaña de macrón de 2017
haciendo lobby en una su plataforma la
república en marcha y bien una de las
cosas que también se muestra en estos
documentos es como se constata que la
promesa de macrón de una tasa a las
gafas a las grandes empresas
tecnológicas no verá la luz del día
bueno rosa y precisamente en un tono
satírico el dibujante de sushi hace una
referencia a este servicio de los
lobbies no en toda la polémica del
presidente emmanuel macrón exactamente
en la davis de cine que siempre comenta
la actualidad con estos dibujos tan
satíricos vemos cómo pinta a emanuel
macrón como un repartidor de uber y dice
señor lobby al que le abre la puerta su
desregulación del mercado no le hace
entrega de esta desregulación a que ha
permitido finalmente que estas grandes
empresas operan como lo hacen en el
territorio francés y básicamente le dice
no olviden misas cinco estrellas y
recordemos que es que precisamente
cuando se ha cuestionado al actual
presidente de la republica de manuel
macro por a su papel cuando era ministro
d economía y favorecer la desregulación
para permitir la operación de uber en
francia él ha respondido que über ha
servido para hacer el trabajo el primer
trabajo de muchos jóvenes sobre todo de
clases trabajadoras de clases populares
que no habrían encontrado otro trabajo
si no hubiera sido pues la conducción de
uber o de uverito no como vemos aquí
esto repartidores sin mencionar no hay
un poco condenado a ciertas clases a la
precariedad absoluta de este trabajo
recordemos inseguros y no con sueldos
mínimos siendo falsos autónomos etcétera
rózsa cambiamos ahora de tema vamos con
una información de eeuu porque un
tribunal de manhattan condenó a un ex
informático de la silla por filtrar
documentos a wikileaks que pasó en este
caso
se trata de joshua schulte un hombre de
33 años a que era informático para la
cia hasta que renunció en 2016 bien
schulte este hombre filtró más de 8 mil
documentos a wikileaks documentos a que
revelaban
como lo hacía digamos los mecanismos de
la ciudad para hackear dispositivos
extranjeros de organizaciones y de
personas básicamente en el extranjero no
en ese momento wikileaks lo filtró en
2017 un poco cuestionando si la
posibilidad las capacidades de la guía
de la cia para hackear pues a otras
personas un poco excedían o lo que sería
el legítimo o incluso legal bien en todo
caso el juez federal de manhattan que
emitió la sentencia dijo que condenaba
al zulte por uno de los actos de
espionaje más dañinos de la historia de
eeuu por socavar los esfuerzos para
luchar contra las organizaciones
terroristas y otras influencias malignas
alrededor del mundo no porque alega
digamos el juez que suelte pasando estos
documentos a wikileaks dio a conocer
algunas de las herramientas de
inteligencia más críticas que tiene eeuu
al público y por lo tanto a sus
adversarios y queríamos comentar un poco
la importancia de este caso porque toda
esta filtración digamos que wikileaks
como bolt 7 dañó mucho la imagen de la
cia hay un fado bastante a los servicios
de inteligencia de eeuu que tal y como
nos dijo baltasar garzón que coordina la
defensa internacional del fundador de
wikileaks julian assange digamos a la
defensa atribuye esta persecución
política contra assange a una motivación
de los servicios de inteligencia de eeuu
no que pues digamos una de las razones
de esta voluntad de persecución sería
este caso no porque digamos los cargos
contra espionaje por espionaje
atribuidos a sancho digamos que pesan
sobre julian assange fueron digamos a
puestos hoy a un año después de estas
revelaciones rosa como siempre gracias
entonces por toda la información esta
revista de prensa del jueves mañana con
más pasamos a saludar a nuestro primero
invitado